[Music]
hi my name is takos Gia I'm an associate
professor of Economics at Stanford
Graduate School of Business my favorite
class is manager economics which I have
been teaching for more than 10 years
today I will talk about five takeaways
from the
class when we hear the word economics we
we often think about business cycle GDP
interest rate and other economic
indicators in my opinion however the
most fundamental benefit of learning
economics is to understand how
economists think about human behavior
and its
consequences that helps you guide your
decision
[Music]
making in economics we model economic
entities as purose full agents namely
participants of economic
activities understand the objectives and
constraints and try to achieve the best
outcome subject to the
constraints for example you are a CEO of
a company and your objective can be
maximizing The Profit maximizing the
market share and so on and the
constraint can be how much quantities
demanded by consumers given a particular
price how strong your arrival is and so
[Music]
on if you want to maximize the objective
a simple yet very powerful rule of thumb
is marginal thinking that means imagine
what happens if you change your behavior
a little bit toward One
Direction if that that improves the
objective then keep going towards that
direction if that reduces the objective
then move the opposite direction if you
are at optimal a small change does not
change the objective
much for example suppose you want to
maximize your profit by setting an
optimal price if you try to increase the
price and the profit increases then the
optimal price is higher than the current
price if you try to increase the price
and the profit goes down then the
optimal price is lower than the current
price if your current price is optimal
then a small change of the price should
not change the profit
[Music]
much the next question is is what
happens if there are multiple decision
makers interacting with each other in
that case each one of them tries to
maximize their own
objectives in some cases other
participants activities affect your
objective or
constraints for example your company's
profit given a particular pricing
strategy of yours is likely to be
affected by the Lial company's pricing
strategies the stable outcome of such
interaction which we call an equilibrium
is defined as the state in which each
participant maximizes its own objective
taking what other participants are
currently doing as
given an important concept to understand
how equilibrium works is adverse
selection in the 1980s American Airlines
offered a lifetime first class ticket to
fly
anywhere American Airlines looked at the
average spending of the frequent flyers
and determined the price of this
ticket however the only people who
bought this product were people who fle
all the time as a result American
Airlines was losing money the problem is
consumers try to maximize their own
objectives namely buying the ticket only
if it is worth its money as a
consequence American Airlines attracted
an adversarially selected pool of
customers compared to their overall
customer base this example remind us
that when we consider our business
strategy it is always good to remember
the possibility of other
[Music]
section I have two daughters she was
kind of saying that oh I want to go to
Stanford and the get an office next to
your office or something like that so at
least she has a positive impression
about being a professor at Stanford I'm
not interest how much she understand
what it means but
[Music]
yeah